now last week um you spent
a day looking at three words that
started with m that you've met before
right what are the words
thank you mean um and it's worth even
though you've um
been looking at these already i'd love
you to write them again because we're
going to briefly discuss them and learn
some stuff about them that'll help us do
the next exercise
mean median and mode
okay emily has a song that helps you
remember which is which
is it is it a rhyme that has to do with
um a cat
is the one that you see the most in the
range of the difference
yeah well i might i've seen it before i
should make a poster at it and print
that we can all look at it
no it works okay well let's just run
with it right now what i'm going to do
is just quickly
revise like what is each one but more
importantly this is what 11
e is about like when do you pick do you
remember when we were looking at um
sample sizes and all that kind of thing
and which kind of sample should you
choose
and the hardest thing about all of this
is not calculating it but
choosing one that's tricky okay so let's
remember
for the mean how do we find the mean
i'll give you a clue
it's a fraction
uh okay so you said a couple of things
there and they kind of sort of gel
together
and the mean is also called the average
but the way to find an average is to add
up all the
scores so that's the sum and then the
thing you divide by as many you
mentioned was
how many scores do you have so it's the
sum of the scores
divided by the number of scores
i've written it in this particular way
because you'll find this exact wording
on the formula and data sheet
out of all three of these this is the
only one that's there
but that's okay because if you think
about the other two and the definitions
you don't need a formula for either of
these
um as the rhyme says the median is there
it's the middle score now i actually
want to give you a slightly better
definition for that
it's a score such that
there's the same number of scores above
you and the same number of scores
below you let me write that and then why
i think this is a better definition
it's a score such that
there's the same number above as below
okay now um the reason why i point this
out
is that remembering the middle is a good
idea for
like remembering the concept of it
but the problem with saying the median
is the middle score is that there isn't
always a middle score let me give you a
quick example maybe you want to drop
this down on the side
in another color here's a set of scores
which is the middle score now
there there isn't a middle score is
there right because you'd say well the
middle score is like
in between here somewhere it's not this
guy and it's not this guy
it's somewhere in the middle right
exactly so what i have to do is i have
to say
it's the mean it's the average
of the middle scores so that's why the
middle is like
a sort of shorthand definition but it's
not always the middle score because
there isn't always
a middle score so in this case it would
be three plus six on two which we've
mentioned is four and a half
okay so you need to know what the mean
is to find out what the mean
is okay what's the model
okay now we've got them in this order
is occurring a double r or one i always
okay is it two okay
let's fix it again um i've got them in
this order because
this is roughly speaking the order that
you'll um
find them most frequently occurring
actually the average
the average is the one you see over and
over again
um the median comes up next and then the
mode is the least common one okay
so i want to unpack why that is why is
it like this
so let me pull up i have a spreadsheet
here i want to show you
um here we go
okay so here are some scores
okay now i didn't mention
why um i've given this heading right you
might have seen it in the textbook this
phrase
the reason why we call all of these
measures of central tendency
is because they're ways of saying hey in
a group like a group of people
or in a group of scores what's the
center of the group what would be
considered normal
in this group okay so you can see if you
squint really hard you'll see a bunch of
scores on the left it's not that
important
but each one of them is represented by a
column and then this red line is the
average okay now have a look would you
say that's a
fair summary of where the middle of the
group is where the center is
let's see yes but look there's a bunch
above above
a bunch below and they're about the same
distance so i'm happy with that
okay now these arm scores here you can
see i've actually calculated the mean up
there in the top left you can see in the
yellow box to that 23
266 i just fashioned some numbers that
could be like kind of
part-time small income type jobs and the
um annual income that you've got
and these are all in the sort of 20
000's and i've ranked them so you can
see i've got the lowest income there
nineteen thousand and this one here is
twenty eight thousand
okay now this is the average the mean
it's fine
so far but watch what happens if i take
the um
the biggest earner here who's got twenty
eight thousand just give him a little
bit of a raise okay let's say he gets a
big raise
okay now have a look at what's happened
right i've i've
decoupled their income so now it's 280
000.
which i should point out is still not
that crazy there's plenty of people in
our country who earn this amount of
money
okay now have a look at the data and
have a look at what's happened to the
mean in fact
you can have a look at it in two ways
you've got the number at the top and
you've also got the
red line okay is the mean
a good description of the center of this
group
it's not is it right because if you have
a look it's um almost three thirty two
thousand dollars
right and you can see the next person
after our 280 thousand dollar earner
the next person's like 27 000 or
something like that
so every single person in our group
except for one
has a an income that's way below this
mean it's not a good description of the
center
at all okay in fact the mean is only
useful
if you've got data kind of like this we
call it normally distributed
right so therefore um if you got another
color red would be probably the most
useful
you've got to be careful with the mean
right the reason you've got to be
careful
is because it's influenced by really
really high or really low scores like
the one i just showed you
right we have a special name for these
kinds of scores it starts with an o
yeah we call them outliers so
the more um outliers you have and the
more extreme they are
the more you influence things like this
and by the way the reason i picked out
income
is because world incomes are exactly
like this you've got a huge number of
people who have this small amount of
income
and a very tall amount of people a small
amount of people rather than one percent
who are outliers and they throw off your
averages
so um you use this in most cases but if
you've got outliers
if you've got um skewed data you're kind
of in trouble
so using the median now i want to show
you
when the median is more useful here we
go
so here's some data that doesn't really
have outliers the way i've described
before
okay but you see it's kind of leaning
towards one side
rather than the other um this is these
are the scores going higher and higher
and higher this way
so most people are on the negative end
of the spectrum okay
now does anyone remember this is called
a skewed population
does anyone remember what kind of skew
it is
huh now this is such a sneaky thing
we're going to spend some more time on
this but i thought since i'm showing you
the picture i might as well refer to it
this is actually positively skewed it's
kind of like yeah it's it's really
sneaky so the way i remember it is
um you've got a tail here you see that
right you've got a hump here this big
cluster of people
and then you've got a tail when you talk
about which way something is skewed
you're actually referring to which way
the tail is facing okay so the tail is
facing in the positive direction
so it's positive skewed okay now because
you've got lots of people
um sort of going up in really high
values they're taking the mean they're
dragging it up in exactly the same way
that um this guy let's make the change
again
in exactly the same way that this final
score is dragging the mean upwards
okay so over here
all of these guys are dragging the mean
over there but look look at where most
of the people
are this is a much better the median
this is a much better description of
what the center of the group is
okay there's one other useful thing that
you can say so this is talking about the
median now
it's useful for skewed
data like the one we're looking at right
here
it's also really useful if you think
back to this diagram do you remember we
talked about four different
kinds of data four different kinds of
data
some of the data only some of the data
can be averaged
right have a thing what are the kinds of
data do you remember them again
categorical
okay
yeah very good numbers right you're very
cool underneath let's go with
quantitative first i need quantitative
there's two kinds
yep separate ones like one two three
four five and confused when you measure
something like heights or weights or
whatever
and then under categorical the word ones
again there's two
which means there's not like um you know
worst okay best and then what's the
other one okay very good
um so good job when you have a look at
something like say
these guys right these guys are okay for
averages you can average them out just
fine
but if you have a look at something like
this
remember i mentioned like the quality of
an object right so
really terrible sort of okay neutral etc
how are you going to average something
like that they're words you can't
average
words that's the whole problem with this
whole set
but you can take a median of words you
can tell which one the middle word is
that's
uh where you're getting all your scores
okay so it's useful for skewed data
or categorical ordinal data
okay and that's going to be my last um
moment to speak about this last one
remember i said the least common
again it's about the data type right so
i've already said
these two are okay because you could
take the average it's fine
this guy's okay it's because you could
take the median what's left over
yeah this is like oh okay eye color
you can't average it out you can't say
it is a middle eye color either
why not i'm kind of using it because
they don't have any order
yeah like to get them to get them in
a um whoopsie daisy to get them into
something like this
i had to have them ranked did you notice
that i had to go from lowest to highest
et cetera
if you can't order them you can't find a
medium because there's no middle so
therefore for this
nominal data go back for nominal data
the mode is the only thing you can use
but most data that we're looking at that
we're interested is not nominal that's
why this one comes up less frequently
okay